I figured out the simplest scalping
strategy that turns losing traders into
profitable ones. Not only has this
strategy worked for me, but it's also
worked for other traders who have tried
it out and they have turned into being
consistent over the long run. I've
compiled a ton of real trade examples.
So, by the end of this video, you will
know exactly how to execute this
strategy just like these other
profitable traders. To give you a super
quick overview before we dive into the
nuts and bolts of how you can
consistently execute this pattern
yourself every day, all I do is when the
US market opens, I look at the first 30
to 60 minutes. All I'm looking for is a
clean support and resistance level and
then I look for a few key patterns. For
example, right here, there's a nice
double top. All I do then is I see a
nice candlestick pattern and then I
enter in on a trade short, betting that
the market is going to go down. And then
from there, I let the market play out.
I've noticed over time that the market
consistently has a reversal in the first
30 to 60 minutes of a trading day. And
so what this strategy does is it allows
you to take advantage of that reversal.
And then coupling that with looking for
key areas of resistance or support,
you're able to essentially pingpong the
market between those levels, capturing a
big potential profit for a smaller
amount of risk. And this is all I do
every day. This is the only thing I look
for every single day. And it allows my
trading to be super simple and
straightforward so that you can go into
every day with a plan and know how to
execute it instead of what I did before
when I was unprofitable. I was trying to
match what the market was doing and that
just was not profitable. And I know from
teaching a ton of people how to do this,
that's the exact same way they feel as
well. And to help you consistently
execute this strategy, I've created a
free 14page guide that'll walk you
through the major patterns that I use to
look for reversals, look to enter in on
my trades for confirmation every time I
look for this strategy. You can download
it in the link in the description of
this video or using this QR code. Now,
to break this down for you in a simple
entry checklist, the first thing I do
coming into trading every single morning
is look at the big picture. Now, I trade
on a one minute chart of the NASDAQ
futures, but you can really trade this
on any time frame or any market. I have
a lot of students that just trade this
on an hour chart. They use it on crypto.
They use it on forex. You're just
reading the candlesticks at the end of
the day. There's no indicators, anything
fancy. So, that's the big important
thing is that you can trade this
anywhere, but this is what I trade on.
And so the first thing I do when I come
into the market here, I kind of just
zoom out and look at, okay, you know,
the market's opening up here in a
minute. What am I looking for? Right?
Where are the key areas of support and
resistance? Now, there's a big one down
here, and then there's kind of a big one
up here for a resistance level. You
know, it it touched here yesterday, it
touched here today, uh, and then there
was a big bottom down here. And another
thing to keep in mind is there was a
touch here overnight, and then this is
where the market closed the previous
day. And so sometimes the market will
bottom at the previous day's close. So I
just drew this one as well to just keep
in mind for that. And so when the market
opened here, it opens up at 7:30 my
time, but this is just the New York
Stock Exchange opened. So 9:30 Eastern
technically. So all I looked for is
okay, well, we opened and we bottomed
here at that, you know, overnight
previous market close level. And so in
trading, you always want to just keep an
open mind of, okay, I don't know where
the market's going to bounce, but I'm
going to be ready for if it's going to
bounce at an area I like. And so what I
was looking for here was it to
potentially bounce here because it
bounced here once and then it showed
some strength and came back and started
to make a double bottom. That's a really
good key pattern. And so from there, I
pulled up a riskreward tool and I said,
"Okay, if I jump in here and I put my
stop here and I'm risking, let's say,
$90. I'm trading on a small account
right now, trying to grow it again just
to prove that this works on a small
account." Again, you've seen just like
that example I just had before. I've
used this on a large account. You can
use this kind of on any size that you
want. But essentially, what this tool is
showing you is that, okay, if I trade
four contracts, I risk $90. where can I,
you know, if I target, I like to target
three times my risk. If it goes up here,
I'll make around
$270. So, to go into the live recording
of this, because this is an actual trade
I took recently, is once it kind of had
that double bottom, I looked for a buy.
And so, to kind of that's kind of
jumping forwards a little bit, but to go
back to really step two of my process is
look at this downtrend line right here.
That's a big key to these reversals is
seeing that okay well the current
downtrend is broken because if you're
looking for a reversal trade well the
market into a support or resistance
level and I don't have it drawn here on
this chart but we just looked at the the
level that we're bouncing off of the
support level would have been right here
and the key is well the market in a in a
strong downtrend it could just keep
going and break through a support level
and so what you want to do is you want
to first make sure that that downtrend
is actually broken so that it can start
a new uptrend. And so that's what I look
for every time as well is make sure
analyze, look at the candlesticks, just
look at the swings. You don't need to
use any indicators or anything. You're
just looking at the raw data. I also
realized over time that simplified
things way more for me is just looking
at the raw data of the trade. And so
from there, okay, step two, downtrend is
broken clearly when this happens. And
then after that it comes down here and
makes a nice clean double bottom. And
then I, you know, I wasn't quite sure
about it after this candlestick because
this was a really strong bearish
candlestick. I wanted to see a little
more strength. Sometimes in the market
what'll happen after a big candlestick
like this. It'll it'll bounce back a
little bit just because it's
overextended a little bit, but then
it'll continue lower. And so what I was
I waited for is I waited for that
bounce. see if it continued lower with
this candlestick right here.
Essentially, that's it continued lower
and that failed. And so then I put in an
order right there, jumped in long, and
then I let the market play out. I moved
my stop to break even after it broke
this previous high cuz I, you know, I
wanted to take that risk off the table.
You don't want to let the market go in
your favor and then come back and knock
you out at a loss. And then from there,
I just trailed up my stop loss. I put in
a limit order actually at two times my
risk just because the market kind of
felt a little choppy. I was totally
happy getting two times my risk for a
profit and you know it you can clearly
see there it almost hit me and so then I
just elected to kind of move things up a
little bit cuz there was this uptrend
here. I kind of like to manage with that
as well. And then from there it just
looked like it was starting to slow
down. I could I kind of was just reading
into the candlesticks, reading into the
market that, you know, it's either going
to continue higher or if it kind of, you
know, starts to just slow down, I'm
going to move my stop loss up and get
out. You know, it's at that two times my
profit that I already am kind of looking
for. You know, I only risked like $90 on
this trade, so I'm up really two and a
half times right now. And so, at that
point, you know, I'm I'm happy with the
trade. at $250, you know, quickly after,
you know, 20 minutes. And then at that I
called it for the day. I didn't even
have to trade for 60 minutes. So, you
can see my read there was right and the
market kind of started to pull back. And
at that point, that was just a quick
scalp. And so, this is just what I
repeat consistently every single Here is
a great example of using a threeline
strike for an entry with a couple of
other patterns. Basically right here,
this threeline strike pattern that's
happening right now is confirming a
double top coming in. All I like to use
these for are reversal trades. You can
use them for continuation trades as
well, but I like to use them for
reversal trades. And you can see here
the market's come up and it's made at
one top and then essentially you can see
we had momentum and then look at these
multiple candlesticks right here. We
start to slow down. you know, we've kind
of come up here, right? There hasn't
been any bearishness and then all of a
sudden, boom, we have a massive
candlestick right here, showing that
switch in momentum that, okay, you know,
especially with being at this double top
in that same area, you're essentially
confirming that double top, which is
even better and makes it more likely
that this is a good area to enter in on
a threeline strike pattern. And so, I
like to enter in at the break of that
low. This is trading a one minute chart.
The candlesticks right after are pulling
back slightly. And I actually think that
is a even better confirmation if the
market pulls back a little bit and then
continues lower and it doesn't break the
high of that threeline strike pattern.
So if I just zoom in a little bit more
to let this kind of play out. I put in
an entry here right as it breaks below
that threeline strike pattern. And then
I put my stop up here above the double
top. If the market comes up here and I'm
wrong, just get out. You know, the idea
of this is you are entering in really
accurately at the highs and you're
looking for, you know, capturing a whole
swing lower. And so just to kind of
watch this trade played out, you can see
from there it kind of moved all the way
lower and kind of hit a target that I
was looking for more towards the lows.
And so I closed up at about $600 and it
gave a perfect signal at the highs to
get in and then from there I was able to
ride the swing lower and capture a
really nice trade. Here's another
example and this is on the flip side
looking for a long. You can see clearly
I'm looking at a support level here
where the market's bounced once, twice.
There was probably another bounce here
before on the previous area in the chart
that I was looking at. And so I'm
already looking for the big picture of
the market to come down here and bounce.
And to accurately enter and confirm that
the market's going to bounce here is I
looked for the market to make a
essentially it slowed down here and then
it had a strong bullish candlestick here
form and I got in essentially as it was
about to finish closing. I got in a
couple seconds earlier, but I
essentially got in as it created that
threeline strike pattern. And you can
see here, it was actually a candlestick
after the bottom here. It wasn't right
away, but it was still showing me that
switch in momentum, and it gave me an
accurate entry to enter in at the bottom
of the swing, have a tighter stop-loss,
and then capture the reversal back
higher. And so this is super super
powerful for capturing trades like this.
You know, every trade is going to go
slightly different. We're going to go
over that massive one here in a minute,
but this is still a really nice trade to
capture, you know, $4 $500 worth of
profit. Again, just trading 60 minutes
in the morning. And so at that point,
you know, the market kind of slowed
down. I said, "Okay, I want to get out
if it breaks lower because it could just
give that swing back up." And that's
where I kind of got out at about $400
and moved on with my day. Now to go over
this trade that I started out in the
beginning of the video and kind of just
show you walk through managing this
trade and also how to enter and confirm
using this strategy a little bit more
than I've already gone into. Let me walk
you through how I entered and found this
trade. And so initially what I'm seeing
is you can see that the market had a
nice methodical trend up here and then
this bearishness right here showed me
that okay something's changed. We've
broken this uptrend. That's a massive
thing that I like to look for. And then
also this big trend line right here is
drawn from a bigger picture where on a
15 or 5 minute I can see that the market
consistently is coming up to this level.
It comes up here again it's likely to
continue lower. Obviously, if I see the
threeline strike pattern that I like to
see and a couple of other factors and so
seeing that it had this big bearishness
here, that was a great confirmation to
say, okay, the momentum in this market
is switching. You always want to take
that into account. You want to have a
big picture idea of where the market is
going. If you're either using this, you
can see right here. Here's a great
example of using the threeline strike
pattern for a long is there's this nice
upwards trend line. The market comes
down to the trend line, it chops there
for a couple candlesticks and then boom,
you have a massive switch in the
momentum continuing it higher and you
would confirm and use that right here
because you're seeing an uptrend already
in place. You would already drawn that
uptrend off of those three lows,
extended it. Assume that, well, the
market comes down here and gives me a
threeline strike pattern. I'm going to
bet the market's going to go up. You
would have got in here and captured a
nice move after that. But once it comes
up to this trend line, which is a big
picture downtrend line, well, you got to
think of it in the flip side. I think
that this is more likely to push the
market lower. And so I need to make sure
that this shorter term trend is broken,
which happened right here. And that this
bigger picture is going to continue and
take into effect again. And so then the
market broke down here. That's why I
didn't get in up here. You could kind of
say there's a threeline strike pattern
here. That for me was a little too
aggressive. I like to wait for a little
bit more confirmation. We came down
here, had a little bit of a bounce,
showed, you know, some momentum.
Essentially, you could even say this is
a 50% pullback from this area. You can
see it's literally in the middle of that
box. The market likes to do pullbacks
like that that are literally halfway of
the move it just had. And so, it moved
down this far, it pulled back halfway.
That's what this little spike here is.
And then it sold off. And for me, this
isn't a super picture perfect and really
nice looking threeline strike pattern,
but for me, I saw, you know, okay,
there's some movement up here. There's
this big attempt to go higher and then,
you know, it's essentially in this
little mini channel and then this big
candlestick here, especially with the
fact that it wicks higher right here.
This little wick right here, it's it's
essentially like a micro double top. And
then I get in, you know, I I actually
got in down here a little bit because it
was moving pretty quickly, but the
signal there is at the candlestick close
right there. And so that's what I used
to jump in on this and then of course
put a stop up here. Doesn't need to go
all the way up here above this trend
line. You know, what we're trying to do
is risk a tight amount and then have the
big picture potential for the market to
really start moving in our favor. And so
in this trade, I think I'm risking like
$500. The last couple trades were
smaller size, but you know, that's why
you can use this kind of in any account
size. You can scale it up because again,
trading is super scalable. You just use
and find one pattern that works and then
increase the money. You don't need to
try and find more patterns to make more
trades. That's what kind of kept me from
being profitable initially. And so
you'll see here actually once the market
essentially made a pullback here right
here and then moved down, I moved my
stop loss to break even because I want
to kind of tighten up the trade and get
out if it's going to pull back on me.
You know, sometimes the market's just
going to be choppy and all over the
place. I don't want to trade in that. I
want to be in trades and I've noticed
these trades will work out pretty
cleanly in your favor if they're going
to work out. And so from there, you
know, it starts moving down pretty
quickly. I'm trying to see, okay, is
there this downtrend line that I can
kind of expect the market to pull back
to? And again, that's kind of thinking
about, okay, how am I managing this? You
know, as you are trading, you want to be
thinking what to do next based on logic,
not okay, I'm up, you know, almost
$3,000. Uh, you know, I'm really
nervous. This is a lot of money. I need
to get out. Or what if this keeps going?
I could be up 5,000, 10,000. Right? You
can't let your emotions kind of control
what you do. you need to have a logical
plan to trade with. And so once this
kind of got rocketing in one direction,
it gets really far away from the trend
line. And I don't want to hold through a
pullback. You know, at this point,
that's a big pullback to hold through
for it breaking that trend line. And so
I start using kind of more of a tighter
trailing stop-loss with kind of previous
candlestick highs. And you can also see
there is this blue box down here. That's
a support level. And so big picture,
I've looked at, okay, well, the market's
already bounced here a couple times. If
we come down here again, I'm going to
expect that we're going to bounce or
slow down. And this is a really fast
moving, unhealthy move, which is great
to be in if you're in it, but it's
likely to snap back at some point. And I
want to be out when it's going to snap
back. And so that's why I have kind of a
tighter trailing stop-loss. And you can
see it's starting to snap back a little
bit. And I want to give it a little
wiggle room because, you know, these
things can break through a support level
and keep going lower. But in this case,
it kind of starts to chop here. It makes
a double bottom and it essentially
knocks me out here. But I get, you know,
about $3,500, $3,200 worth of profit.
And you can see here the market bounced
right here. And so that's why I'm kind
of thinking, okay, well, if it comes
down here again, I want to see if we'll
bounce again. And so that's kind of the
first thing that I always look for in
this strategy is looking for the market
to bounce at a key level. You don't want
to just be randomly thinking, okay,
well, it'll go here, it'll go there. You
know, that's when you start to become
reactionary to the market. And you want
to actually have a plan and wait for the
market to fit that plan. I have realized
that over time that that's really the
way to become profitable. And the other
part of that is just find one strategy
and one pattern that works. You don't
need to find 10 different strategies and
be trying to capture, you know, every
move in the market because like you just
saw when it comes to the sizing and
scaling these numbers in a way can
become infinitely huge, right? You could
be literally risking $10,000 on a trade
and make, you know,
$40,000 in 20 minutes. Now, that seems
mindblowing because, you know, when I
first started, I was risking literally
like $25, $50, but now in this trade
right here, I'm risking something like
$500. And you'll see the potential can
go really fast once you kind of get this
in play. And so, the next thing I like
to look for is, you can see the market
came down here to this level and it
actually broke this downtrend. So,
that's kind of the second thing I like
to look for when you're looking for
reversals. you need to make sure that
the downtrend is broken. And so what
I've done here is I've kind of confirmed
that after this trend was broken. And so
it's starting to show some strength,
some bullish candlesticks. And I like
that for getting in on a trade, betting
that the market is going to go higher.
Now, kind of the last couple thing I
like to look for is I want to see the
market kind of start to show kind of a
bottoming pattern. Right here, it's
basically making higher highs. And so I
like this as this candlestick was a
really kind of a big bearish candlestick
attempting the market to go lower and it
failed here based on these candlesticks.
And so I like the idea of saying, "Hey,
I want to get in long above this
candlestick right here betting that the
market is going to go higher." And so I
put what is called a buy stop order
above it. If the price of the market
touches this price, put in a market
order. I don't care where you feel me
at. Just get me in the market. And most
of the time you can see it literally
just filled it at that exact price. But
sometimes it can, you know, fill you
right here because the market can move
pretty fast. But that is the order I
like to enter in on most of the time.
And you know, you can use a buy limit
order that'll get you in below or
exactly at that price. But the problem
with that is well for this example right
here well the market kind of took off
here and you would have felt a lot of
FOMO and you would have because you
would have missed out on the trade and
you would have had to wait for and hope
that the market comes back down and
fills you at that price. And so you can
see here quickly just over a couple
candlesticks I'm already up $1,000 on
this trade risking you know I think $500
or $600. And so this is where the power
comes into play is I'm trading four oil
futures contracts here. And you can see
it's moving in that
0.01 increment, that penny size,
compared to the S&P 500 futures that
we're just looking at was actually
moving in that quarter of a point size,
that 0.25. But you can see here clearly
that the money is a lot more. And so for
me, my strategy is I like to kind of get
in when I see, you know, basically you
can easily see here is there's a lot of
momentum here. It started to slow down
by essentially just seeing that the
market kind of started chop here. And
then I look for a couple few key factors
to jump in and catch the momentum to the
other side. And so I moved my stop here
to break even. And then as this starts
to kind of get pretty accelerated here,
I like to use kind of the idea that,
hey, okay, I'm gonna give it a little
bit of wiggle room, but I'm going to
move my stop up if it pulls back
because, you know, I'm up about $2,000.
And, you know, you want to let this
thing run if it's going to run, but you
also, you know, you can see like just as
it pulled back right here, it can
reverse very, very quickly, too. And so,
that's where I really look to, you know,
manage my trades. But again, that's come
with a lot of practice and experience
trading this. You know, my target here,
you can see now that we're getting up to
here. You can see we're kind of in a
support level that I've drawn from
previously in the chart. And that's
where I'm going to expect things to slow
down. And so, you can see I've moved my
stop loss up here. It's, you know, we're
up a lot more money now. And this is
where kind of the power comes into play
of using technical analysis with futures
is you have that leverage and you have
that ease of getting in and out of the
market, but you also have the simplicity
of, you know, you're not having to deal
with the complexity of options and other
factors that come into play with other
assets. And so to just to close this
out, you know, I'm not going to go into
my strategy too much here. I have a lot
more videos on that, but I pretty much
get knocked out right there. Now, this
is a good example of a trade on a small
account. I'm kind of doing a small
account challenge right now. And this is
on a small account. And so, I'm risking
$100 here, betting that the market is
going to reverse off of this resistance
level that I've drawn. And then, you
know, betting it to go probably kind of
down here. And we'll talk about targets
and why that's a good target later. But
if it gets down there, that's a good
two, three times my risk. And on a small
account risking $100, that is a nice
profit. And so the first thing that I'm
looking for obviously is that it comes
up to that level first, right? That is
the number one key thing to make
reversal trading work is the patience to
just wait for the market to come to an
extreme and key level. You can even see
the market came here and reversed off of
this little area right here. You can
say, well, you know, it bounced here, it
bounced here, it bounced here, and so
maybe it bounces here. Maybe I should
have got that. You know, maybe you even
look at hindsight and say, "Oh, I'll try
and get that next time." But those don't
work very often, and they're more likely
to cause you to lose money in the long
run. It's better to just sit out, kill
that noise, and wait for the market to
come to these extremes, and then when
it's oversold or overbought in this
case, you can capture on that strong
reversal to the downside. And so the
first key that I like to use is after
it's kind of hit that level. Again, you
can see it's not quite in my zone, but
again, it's so close, it's good enough.
The first thing is making sure that
uptrend is broken because when you're
counter trend trading, you don't want to
go against a trend because, you know, it
might come up to a level here, but it's
in an uptrend and it's just going to
keep going, right? We don't know. These
these levels aren't going to hold every
time. It's not just blindly sell or buy
at these levels. And so that's kind of
why I have this uptrend here is you can
see that we had strong bullish
candlesticks here and then it it kind of
started to break is it had a dogey here.
It had a bearish candle here and then it
made kind of another push higher. And so
for me that's good enough to say, hey,
yeah, this strong kind of micro trend
right here is broken. And you can see
the market's kind of being quick with
its reversals. And so I'm okay with
thinking that that's a a good enough
trend break. Certain kind of trends,
they'll need something else. But in this
case, for this kind of very one
directional unhealthy trend, it's good
in terms of clearing that kind of need
for a reversal break. And so after that,
my next key that I like to look for is
kind of a reversal pattern or reversal
candlestick pattern. And so in this
case, the market started to show some
weakness here with this kind of dogee
here and this kind of red bar and it
broke that uptrend and then it made
these two candlesticks here, these
bullish candlesticks, breaking this
previous high, this high right here
became a new one. And for me, that said,
okay, it's still going higher. But as
soon as this big bearish candlestick
form right here, this big red one, that
to me is showing it almost made a a
micro failed breakout. made that kind of
trap where it attempted to make a new
high and it it did it made a a new high
but barely at all. You know, it didn't
make much before this big bearish
candlestick came in. And so, if I kind
of zoom back in the recording and kind
of show you that in real time right now,
to speed this up a little, once this
candlestick finishes forming, I think
that's a a good signal for me. And I
want to get in right there at the low of
that candle. So my thought is, okay, I
want to get in when it kind of breaks
the low of this candle because to me
that's a strong enough signal that it's
likely going to reverse there. And so
you can see initially it kind of starts
to go against me and doesn't look great
initially, but you know that's where
when things reverse sometimes they take
a little while. The market won't always
just reverse on a dime. A lot of times
it'll come up like it did, kind of start
to settle down and slow and lose some of
that momentum and strength, and then
it'll give it back up and start going.
And so that's what I'm kind of looking
for. And so for once I entered in there,
I moved my stop above this high because
the whole idea is if it comes up here
and knocks me out, you know, I'm looking
for that kind of quick reversal to fail.
And I think if it comes up here, comes
back down and and keeps going higher, I
think that's a stronger uptrend. It's
had a healthy pullback if it does that
and then it keeps going higher and you
know I I want to get out. The idea is
with trading is you take your stabs,
they either work out really quickly and
really well right away or they just
don't work out and you move on. If
you're trying to force a trade in
conditions where it's just not great and
not working out, you're going to lose
money if you try and enter in the market
over and over. So once it kind of got
going in my favor here, and again this
is on a small account. I think I'm
risking it honestly might be like $80 or
$90, not even 100. But the idea is I
moved my stop loss here to break even
because well, if you look at where we're
at here, we had a news, this was just a
news announcement. I'm trading the
NASDAQ futures here. Again, you can kind
of trade this on anything you want
because you're just reading the
candlesticks. But there was kind of a
news announcement that made a big spike
right here. And then from there, we've
been in kind of this choppy range. And
so my worry is here is I do think we can
reverse off of here and push back down
and kind of push back to here. We'll
talk about that in a second. But I'm
looking for, you know, that to reverse,
right? I don't want to lose money if
instead the market's just going to be in
this mode where it kind of just sits
here and goes in a sideways chop. I'm
looking for kind of a little bit larger
of a move where I, you know, risk a
small amount and make a large amount.
And so when it kind of had this initial
move right here and it could have
reversed right here off that big green
candle and I would like to get out at
break even at that point. And so you
know once it kind of did that I moved to
break even and instead it kind of just
had a little pullback which is good
actually in terms of the health of this
move down. And then from there once it
starts to kind of make a new low I
actually moved my stop loss down here
again to again capture some of those
profits because I'm thinking that this
market is pretty tight. I think it's
more likely that it kind of whips back
and forth and I'd rather get out with a
small decentsized little one times my
risk, maybe one and a half times my risk
win versus leaving it here and, you
know, hoping a home run happens because
those do happen and I catch those. But
you have to pick your spots, right? You
don't always want to be managing the
same way with your trades. And so here
you can see that I've actually drawn a
downtrend line here. And I think that's
a really nice way to manage 10 because
it looks like it's starting kind of to
be in this little downtrend. And the
second thing is, well, we're getting
close to this area. Now, this isn't a
major support level. It's not something
I have on a larger time frame. That's
why there's not really a zone drawing
there. This is where you want to use as
smaller targets for your trades, though,
because especially in a market like this
where I don't think it's going to be a
home run. I think it's more likely to
bounce and reverse off of a micro
support resistance level. Now, I'm not
necessarily taking my bets and trades
off of those levels. But in terms of if
I think the market's going to be pretty
tight today and I want to just capture a
nice little swing like this and then get
out at at a nice profit, I'm okay using
that. And a lot of the times when the
market has a big move like this, kind of
like we were talking about earlier that
it's a big area where the market
velocity off that area was really big,
it's more likely that when the market
comes back down there, it's going to
find a bounce and it's going to find
some buyers and support. And this trade
right here is going to dry up and slow
down. And I want to capture my profits
here because I'm getting, you know,
about two two and a half times my risk
on this trade. And that is a great trade
to just consistently make money and grow
your trading account. And again, that's
what you want to start out with. You
don't want to be trying to get home
runs, make a ton of money. Make your
small account grow over time. And in
this, you can 10x this size. I have
trades on my channel where this trade
would be $2,000. And it's the exact same
setup. And so, actually, at that point,
you can see I had my stop loss down
there because I was managing it pretty
tight because we got down to this other
area. and it closed out there and it
actually started to reverse and you can
see it started to reverse off that
level. And so just looking at right
here, pause the video and kind of think
about what patterns you're seeing that
we just went over. There's a couple here
that you can see. So I'm just going to
give a couple seconds just pause it and
just kind of see if you can see what
these patterns are. And then from there
to kind of walk you through what I'm
seeing is, you know, we kind of have a
big support, excuse me, resistance level
here. And the markets come up in, you
know, kind of just a methodical uptrend,
right? And then all of a sudden, we have
a massive move up causing in my mind a
big shift. You know, this is out of
nowhere. The the trend was clearly just
kind of chugging along, do its thing,
and then boom, it has a big move. And so
for me, that's a switch in what's going
on. an overexhaustion usually. And so
from there it moves up, pulls back, has
one more attempt higher here. And then
kind of to zoom in on this area, looking
at these candlesticks as well is there's
a threeline strike pattern here. It kind
of shows up a little funky, but you
know, it's pretty much just a couple of
sideways candles and then it slowly
moves up and then over this candlestick
here, it moves up and reverses and then
the next candle it just gives it back
up. And so for me, I, you know, waited
to see a couple candlesticks how it
responded. You know, that's kind of the
intricacies of getting in short and just
playing these strategies over time.
You'll kind of see how you like to play
in a couple spots. But then I entered in
on a trade there. Put my stop loss above
here because my thought is, hey, if it
comes up here, I just want to get out.
You know, this is obviously a strong
move. If it's going to keep going
higher, it's going to go pretty quickly.
or if it if it reverses and gives back
this move up, I like it's going to
happen quickly as well because these
moves, they generally happen quickly.
And so this is again on a small account.
I'm risking about $100 here, maybe a
little even under, I don't quite
remember. But the big thing I'm looking
for here is zooming it forwards a bit is
I went to break even here once it kind
of gets moving in my favor. And you
know, you can see I drew this support
box because my thing is I'm thinking
that it's gonna a lot of the times like
we talked about earlier with these
targets or with these moves a good
target is it gives back this kind of
overextension or overexhausted move.
That happens a lot of the time and once
it kind of gives back there then it's
kind of you know it's back more in
equilibrium and you know I for me my
edge is gone. you know, I I have a good
understanding of how these move. I don't
have a good understanding of how they
move after, but that's okay, right? You
only need one or two patterns to be
consistently profitable trading. And so,
this is my pattern, right? And so, for
me, I liked the idea of scaling out of
my trade. This is a little more
advanced, but I, you know, broke up my
stop losses of saying, "Okay, I want to
get out of, you know, three out of five
of my contracts right here if it decides
to snap back quickly." And then I also
want to just kind of give this other one
a little more wiggle room if it's going
to bounce here and then keep going
lower. You know, this can be a big
switch in the overall trend. And so I
want to give it a little room. You know,
as you can see, I moved it down there. I
do kind of have a kind of mental stop in
my head. Now, I quickly moved it back,
but you can see I'm kind of I'm trying
to give it a couple of candlesticks of a
pullback here. And then most likely I'll
move it down once it kind of starts to
reverse or you know kind of gets to
either 1x my risk. You know the idea is
I want to give it some wiggle room but I
don't want to try and give it you know
give this whole swing back up. And so
kind of it starts to reverse there. And
so I'm going to move my stop down now
because this is kind of a a little micro
top. you know, I think if it's going to
make this little micro double top and
keep going lower, that's a great spot
for my stop because if it breaks this,
you know, I think it's, you know, it's
it's kind of not doing what I'm looking
for. And that's how I like to manage my
trade is if it's doing what I want. And
so from there, you know, it just kind of
chopped around a little bit and looks
like it was breaking lower here. And so
it starts to break lower. I'm moving my
stop down. And again, it's still kind of
in this range. You can see here. And
this kind of looks like a little bit of
a little mini fail breakout, you could
even say. Um, and I believe it it knocks
me out here. And so that trade still
closed up at, you know, I think two two
times my risk. Really good profitable
trade right there, which is, you know, a
great growth on a small account. And so,
make sure to download that 14page free
candlestick patterns guide in the link
in the description of this video or with
this QR code right here. It'll really
help you consistently execute this
strategy and show you more patterns that
I use to enter in on other than the
quick ones I just went through. As well,
if you want a more in-depth guide into
this strategy and more trade examples to
kind of flush out how it actually works,
check out this video right here.